kalimera patriotic over the next two
minutes I want to talk to you about
something that to keep your interest up
but put out interest down Greece it is
admitted to reign in democracy
consisting of over 2,000 islands and
4,000 British backpackers we have a long
history of creating some revolutionary
ideas democracy philosophy
Jonnie we were doing excess body hair
before hipsters and we were doing
same-sex everything before it was cool
and also lamb on a spit we invented it
the alarm clock we invented it the
Olympics we invented it our history of
innovation has put us on the map which
we also invented but it could all come
to a dramatic halt you see after
inventing everything we got tired and
arrested on our laurels which we also
invented and now because we haven't
invented anything in a long time we are
the world 371 billion euros we were this
close to invent in the iPod but you know
it was a sunny day and those free azure
in Syntagma square so some people said
to me but if you didn't smash so many
plates you'll be able to pay off the
debt quicker and I say yes but if we
didn't smash the plates we'd have to pay
someone to wash them up no some people
complain they go all perhaps we should
rein in spending stop tax avoidance and
corruption and I say here take this
little envelope of cash which we
invented and they never complain again
and that's where you come in with just a
little help from you we can get back to
inventing things when you donate to our
Glick starter you don't have to go home
empty-handed
here are the rewards bronze-level for
100 euro you'll get the personal F
hottest off from a Greek of your choice
it could be Arianna Huffington or Uncle
Jesse or anyone whose name ends in
openers whether they are Greek or not
for a hundred thousand euro you could
live your dream of being a backup dancer
in Eurovision anyone can do it even if
you are old or young or something else
silver medal dollars for every one
hundred million dollar donation you can
become the owner of some high-class
Olympic venues they have only been used
by one Olympic Games and some seats were
never used
gold medal donors for 10 million euro or
more you can buy the naming rights to
our beautiful country
imagine your name here Steve
Equatorial Germany Markella nose or even
Idris come on Apple give us some caption
in 2015 help Greece finish what we
started in 447 BC a Far East all for
listening and remember Greece is the
word
what's another thing we invented the
automobile has remained largely
unchanged for over a hundred years at
Apple we thought how can we set it up